- Creation, transformation,
the quest for self-knowledge.
These are universal themes
that appear across world mythology.
But there's another common
thread within these tales:
gender fluidity.
- It's not only commonplace
in many mythologies,
but an essential aspect of some
important mythical figures:
from androgynous creators
and fertility deities
to warriors and prophets
that defy the gender binary.
(mysterious music)
- These figures challenge the belief
that sex and gender are
split into male and female.
Since ancient times,
societies have recognized
the existence of more than two genders.
While the language used
to refer to these different identities
and experiences varies hugely,
transgender, intersex,
and nonbinary people
have always existed
and played a crucial
role in world mythology.
So why was the ability to bend
and transcend gender sacred,
and what do these figures tell
us about gender in society?
- When it comes to creation myths,
many primordial deities
cannot be understood
as solely male or female.
For instance, a Babylonian
creation myth sees Tiamat,
or salt water, mingle
with Abzu, or fresh water,
to create the rest of the gods.
The Babylonian source,
called the Enuma Elish,
refers to the primordial
Tiamat as both he and she.
However, 19th century European scholars
revised the original myths
to fit their own standards of gender,
referring to Tiamat as female
and often characterizing them
as a monstrous sea goddess.
Similarly, the Aztec
creator deity Tlaltecuhtli
was described as an earth
lord and a reptilian monster
with feminine and masculine attributes.
When they waded into the sea
looking for flesh to eat,
the other gods ripped Tlaltecuhtli in half
to form the earth and the sky.
Much later, European
colonizers recast Tlaltecuhtli
as a motherly earth goddess,
simplifying their complex
role as a formidable protector
who is also a flesh-eating destroyer.
Another Aztec god, Ometeotl,
was also a genderless agent of creation.
Ometeotl created themself, the
universe, and the other gods,
and resided in the 13th
and highest heaven alone.
While some sources have framed Ometeotl
as a husband and wife
pairing within one god,
others have argued
that this is an overly
simplistic understanding
of their gender.
Colonial retellings often
simplified these creator deities,
using gendered tropes
like the fearsome lord or gentle mother.
But the original myths
don't conform to cliches.
Instead, nonbinary primordial deities
embody the duality of creation,
distilling the twinned energies
of birth and destruction,
wonder and dread.
- In the Tagalog mythology of
the Philippines for instance,
Lakapati was worshiped
as a goddess of the fields and fertility
who was represented
with reproductive organs
traditionally labeled male and female.
This representation of Lakapati's gender
may have associated her
with balance and abundance.
Similarly, certain androgynous deities
were associated with fertile
land in Ancient Egypt.
As the annual flooding
of the Nile approached,
the Egyptians appealed
to Hapi for rich soil.
Hapi was seen as a fatherly figure
who sported the false
beard of the Pharaoh,
full breasts, and a pregnant belly.
Intersex children, who
were believed to be sacred,
sometimes served at Hapi's temple.
Another Egyptian icon, Wadj-Wer,
was depicted as a
blue-green pregnant deity
who protected lakes and lagoons.
In both these figures,
fertility is not understood
as a purely masculine
or feminine attribute.
Because the Ancient Egyptians believed
that men carried the fetus
before transferring them to women,
the idea of the pregnant
man was not uncommon.
The concept is making a comeback today
as advocates push for
more inclusive language
in traditionally feminine spaces.
When an Ancient Egyptian woman died,
priests temporarily transformed
her corpse into a man,
just long enough for
her to create a fetus,
thus ensuring rebirth in the afterlife.
They did this by reciting spells
and changing the corpse's
pronouns in prayer,
as well as painting its skin red.
The corpse then returned to female form,
ready to rebirth herself.
This ritual is one way in
which gender transformation
was commonplace, and desirable,
in Ancient Egyptian life and afterlife.
- While gender transformation
was an accepted part of life
in some mythologies and cultures,
other traditions reflect a
more ambivalent approach.
Classical myth is full of gods and humans
turning into plants and animals,
but there are lesser-known
figures who change their genders.
In Ancient Greek mythology,
at the hands of various gods,
Tiresias' gender was
changed up to six times,
depending on the source.
Tiresias served as a
male prophet of Apollo,
but also married and had
children in female form.
They were known for settling
disputes between the gods,
like the time Zeus and Hera asked them
to compare the sexual
experiences of men and women,
and to advise famous
warriors like Odysseus.
Tiresias' transformations
have traditionally been
depicted as godly punishments,
but there's another way to
read their gender fluidity.
Tiresias was adept at
absorbing new experiences
and inhabiting different roles,
skills that also make them a wise prophet
and skilled mediator.
Classical myths
offer a range of gender
identities, with figures
like the gender-bending
god of pleasure Dionysus
and the androgynous love
deity Hermaphroditus
celebrated in art and literature.
One moonlit tribute to Hermaphroditus
involved men and women
swapping their clothes.
Other sacred rites
involving dance, drinking,
and mind-bending substances
invited marginalized figures
like women and non-Greek
citizens to express themselves.
Scholars have noted the
existence of the galli,
priests who were assigned male
at birth but lived as women,
as a recognized group in society
who determined their
own gender presentation.
But they were a small
and privileged group,
and it is likely that many more
gender non-conforming people
have slipped through the
cracks of classical history.
- Still, across world mythology,
myths of gender fluidity testify
to the material existence
of many gender identities
throughout history.
Gender fluidity often
acts as a powerful symbol
for heroism and self-determination.
In Philippine Suludnon lore for instance,
maidens known as binukots
could transform into male
warriors in an emergency,
rescuing their friends,
searching for their husbands,
and engaging in righteous combat.
In Hindu mythology, Shikhandi
is assigned female at birth
but later transforms into a man
with the help of a Yaksha
or benevolent spirit.
Known as Shikhandi, he
becomes a great warrior
and works to overthrow Bhishma,
a king who had abducted
and humiliated him.
These myths depict gender transformation
as a powerful model for
adaptation and spiritual growth.
Beyond the story of Shikhandi,
Hindu cosmology offers some
of the richest understandings
of the gender spectrum.
In the Ramayana, the god
Rama retreated into exile,
only for his devotees to
follow him out of love.
He ordered all men and women
to return to their homes
so he could be alone,
but when he finally emerged from exile,
he found that those who did
not identify as male or female
had waited for him.
Rama blessed these apparent outcasts
and gave them permission to
bless newborns in ritual,
thus testifying to the
importance of inclusion.
Commonly called Hijras,
these blessed individuals
have historically been aligned
with fertility, music, and liminality,
testifying to their spiritual significance
in Hindu scripture.
But even the divinely blessed
aren't guaranteed happy lives.
While Hijra are an integral
part of the culture,
they often face discrimination and abuse.
This shift from acceptance
to discrimination
was heavily influenced by
British colonialism in India.
In the 1860s and 70's for instance,
British settlers compiled
registers of Hijras
that used derogatory language
and stripped them of their rights.
This is just one instance of
how colonial policies and texts
have attacked gender
diversity across the world.
From revising ancient myths
to conform to binary gender,
to dismantling human rights,
Western colonialism has sadly
imposed the gender binary
on mythologies and
material realities alike.
- Today, efforts to recognize
and celebrate gender fluidity,
in ancient myths and
modern times, continue.
Ancient gender fluid deities
show us that trans and nonbinary
identities are nothing new,
and queer and gender nonconforming people
continue to find community
through these mythical figures.
For instance, thousands of
trans and nonbinary people
partake in the Chamayavilakku
festival in Kollam each year,
celebrating their protector
goddess Bhagavati-devi.
Contemporary artists and writers
have also used ancient deities
to explore gender expression.
- Whether reclaiming the gender queerness
of mythical creatures and deities.
- Or subverting gender
roles in ancient myth.
- Or decolonizing world mythology.
- These efforts emphasize the importance
of representation and
expression for all genders.
(gentle music)